the chaplain of the House of
Representatives who had been forced out
by House Speaker Paul Ryan will now stay
on the job father Patrick Conroy had
agreed to step down later this month at
the speaker's request but in a letter
yesterday the 67 year old Roman Catholic
priest told Ryan that after consulting a
lawyer he was rescinding his resignation
Ryan says Conroy will remain in his
position ed O'Keefe is on Capitol Hill
with how this unlikely dispute unfolded
and then this latest turn ed good
morning good morning John this whole
situation causing a lot of bipartisan
head-scratching members of both parties
want to know why exactly
Conroy was asked to resign the chaplain
himself now suggests so the prayer he
gave last fall during the GOP tax reform
debate may have been seen by the
speaker's office to be too political I'm
not coming a defiant father Patrick
Conroy resurrected his tenure as House
chaplain yesterday afternoon issuing
this searing two-page resignation
retraction letter to House Speaker Paul
Ryan saying I have never been
disciplined nor reprimanded nor have I
ever heard a complaint about my ministry
during my time as House chaplain some of
Conroy's defenders believe the
controversy dates back to a prayer he
delivered in November during debate over
the GOP tax reform plan may their
efforts these days guarantee that there
are not winners and losers under new tax
laws but benefits balanced and shared by
all on Monday at an event in Milwaukee
Ryan defended his decision a number of
our members felt like the pastoral
services were not being adequately
served but father Conroy states in his
letter that when Ryan's chief of staff
Jonathan Burks asked for his resignation
he mentioned my November prayer and made
a dismissive comment something like
maybe it's time we had a chaplain that
wasn't a Catholic Burke's disputed those
statements saying I am disappointed by
the misunderstanding but wish him the
best as he continues to serve the house
any suggestion that the Catholics need
not apply is deeply offensive to
Virginia Democratic congressman Gerry
Connolly who is cast
says reaction to Conroy's ouster in the
house was nearly universal that went
from shock to outrage and I might say
not just Democrats lots of Republicans
as well House Minority Leader Nancy
Pelosi applauded the decision but says
she wants to know more about this whole
situation and in his statement
announcing Conroy's reinstatement the
speaker said he wanted to avoid a
drawn-out fight in hopes to meet with
the chaplain when Congress is back in
town next week Gail all right thank you
very much